cuando queremos categorizar la vida como
la conocemos y digamos a muy grandes
rasgos podemos dividir en dos categorías
tenemos primero las células eucariontes
esta sería una célula eucariontes y por
otro lado también tenemos las células
provocar y antes muy bien también
tenemos las células provocar y antes y
la diferencia más grande entre estos dos
son las estructuras membrana les de
frontera que los los organismos educar y
antes tienen y los organismos
procariotas no y la más notable de ellas
digamos de estas estructuras es la pared
membrana del núcleo de hecho en un
eucariontes verdad aquí tenemos el
núcleo en una eucariontes la información
genética se encuentra dentro de una
membrana que encierra el núcleo así que
vamos a escribir esto esta estructura
que tenemos aquí es el núcleo de nuestra
célula muy bien de hecho dentro de este
núcleo es en donde podemos encontrar el
a
pero si comparamos por ejemplo con los
organismos procariotas verdad entonces
podemos ver que el adn se encuentra
acomodado digamos todo se encuentra
acomodado en una sección que llamamos el
núcleo jde pero en esencia no tiene un
núcleo con una frontera hembra membrana
al verdad entonces podemos decir que los
pro calientes tienen un núcleo tienen un
núcleo sin una frontera membrana ok sin
fronteras membrana
hembra ok y por supuesto no es la única
diferencia entre eucariontes y pro car y
antes de hecho por ejemplo si nos
remontamos digamos a la etimología de
los eucariontes por ejemplo aquí la
parte digamos que dice que antes verdad
se refiere esencialmente a no es un
núcleo que entonces vamos a escribir
esto se refiere esto a no es o bien
puede también digamos interpretarse como
núcleo muy bien por otro lado para los
pro car y antes digamos tenemos esta
parte que dice pro que significa antes
verdad entonces estamos hablando de
antes del núcleo muy bien y por supuesto
no es todo no son todas las diferencias
verdad hay otras estructuras membrana
les que no vas a encontrar en los
propios test por ejemplo aquí tenemos
estas estructuras ver bueno que pinte en
verde verdad estas estructuras de aquí
son las mitocondrias
las mitocondrias muy bien las
mitocondrias son una estructura que no
se encuentran en los propios test pero
que sí se encuentran en los eucariontes
podemos ver otro ejemplo de estructuras
verdad y lo que tenemos justamente aquí
en esta micrografía verdad en esta
micrografía es el aparato de golgi y el
aparato de golgi esencialmente tiene la
función de empaquetar algunas proteínas
de hecho por ejemplo aquí tenemos una
micrografía de lo que es la mitocondria
verdad y aquí tenemos una micrografía
del núcleo aunque esto exactamente está
digamos está en círculo que se ve muy
claro en la micrografía este es el
núcleo verdad ahí se encuentra la
membrana nuclear lo que acabo de
circular y todo el adn se encuentra
digamos pegado aquí en forma de
cromatina verdad y en realidad está
regado por todos lados pero
principalmente en una zona verdad que se
encuentra digamos aquí que se ve mucho
más denso y que se ve
más oscuro verdad entonces a esta a esta
parte se le conoce como el núcleo lo de
hecho es lo que corresponde por ejemplo
a esta zona que tenemos aquí verdad en
esta en este dibujo que tenía antes y de
hecho en el núcleo lo es donde se
produce el arnés ribosomas que de hecho
digamos forma parte de la estructura de
los ribosomas que digamos son son
esenciales en la construcción de
proteínas verdad basados en la
información
del arn mensajero y de hecho esto lo
veremos más adelante verdad pero bueno
aquí podemos observar los ribosomas que
están pintados como con este color
naranja
los ribosomas esencialmente están hechos
de arne ribosomas y proteínas y sólo
para ser claros los ribosomas también
están presentes en las estructuras
perdón en las células provocaré antes
verdad aquí también se encuentran los
ribosomas así que la distinción clave
entre los organismos eucariontes y los
pro calientes es que en las células
eucariontes hay
núcleo con una frontera membrana ok y
bueno hay otras diferencias como la
presencia de mitocondrias verdad de
hecho hay una teoría que dice que la
mitocondria evolucionó inicia
inicialmente como como organismos
procariotas y quedé empezaron a vivir en
simbiosis con las células eucariontes
más grandes
ok pero bueno es una es una teoría muy
interesante ahora bien hay otra
diferencia en las células eucariontes
verdad el adn se encuentra distribuido
digamos como en varias obras ok o en
varios digamos podemos pensarlo en como
en varios hilos verdad mientras que en
las células provocar y antes en realidad
el adn es circular muy bien y digo no
necesariamente se tiene que ver así
podría ser que esté muy enrollado pero
esencialmente termina digamos uniéndose
con el inicio así que en resumen tenemos
tres diferencias la primera diferencia
es que tenemos una membrana nuclear
nuclear perdón
y bueno la segunda diferencia es que
tenemos otros organelos con frontera
membrana al por ejemplo la mitocondria o
digamos el aparato de golgi y la tercera
diferencia es que el adn se encuentra en
varias obras en las células eucariontes
mientras que tenemos adn circular en las
células provocar entes muy bien otra
diferencia por ejemplo entre los entre
los educarían test y los pro calientes
es que los eucariontes suelen ser más
grandes que los pro calientes ok de
hecho estos últimos tienden a ser más
pequeños y más simples ahora que ya
sabemos las diferencias digamos las
diferencias principales entre
eucariontes y provocarían test veamos
algunos ejemplos de eucariontes muy bien
así que vamos a hacer esto un poquito
más arriba muy bien aquí tenemos digamos
un primer ejemplo de célula eucariontes
esta imagen de aquí corresponde al
parámetro verdad que de hecho es un
protesta verdad entonces hay algunos
ejemplos de organismos unicelulares que
pueden
eucariontes como el parámetro pero
esencialmente los educarían test también
contienen en esta categoría a los
organismos multicelulares entonces todo
organismo multicelular que es bueno
quizás no todo organismo pero digamos
los más conocidos lo que son las plantas
animales y hongos son organismos
multicelulares que son educar y antes y
por eso tienen membrana celular y otros
órganos bien de hecho por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una imagen en donde podemos ver
las células de la punta de la raíz de
una cebolla muy bien de hecho ésta está
digamos fotografía se utilizó con algún
método de tinción verdad para que puedas
digamos puedan ser teñidos estas estos
circulitos que podemos ver aquí que
esencialmente son los núcleos son los
núcleos y que se ve que están acotados
por la membrana verdad y de hecho esta
es una imagen increíble porque se ven
distintas etapas de la mitosis verdad
que es la división celular esencialmente
verdad
entonces ya hemos dicho en digamos en la
categoría de los organismos eucariontes
podemos encontrar animales hongos
plantas los organismos protistas verdad
y bueno por supuesto podríamos pensar en
lo en en ti mismo verdad en los seres
humanos las células que te hacen ser tú
mismo son células eucariontes ahora bien
veamos algunos ejemplos procar y antes
verdad y esencialmente digamos el
ejemplo más clásico son las bacterias
verdad estas estructuras o estos
organismos que vemos aquí que digamos
tienen forma de píldora estos de aquí
son bacterias muy bien y esos son pro
calientes ahora bien también tenemos
otro tipo de organismos que son las
arqueas y hace muchos años se creía que
eran bacterias que vivían en condiciones
extremas pero ahora sabemos que en
realidad el digamos el dominio de las
arqueas es un dominio distinto de la
vida que no son bacterias muy bien
de hecho hablando de los dominios de la
vida digamos hasta ahora se cree que
digamos la evolución ha sido más o menos
de esta forma que esencialmente tenemos
digamos el dominio de las bacterias muy
bien después tenemos también el dominio
de las arqueas arqueas y por aquí
tenemos también el dominio de los
eucariontes muy bien aquí podríamos
pintar el dominio de los eucariontes
eucariontes y solo para remarcar
recordemos que las bacterias y las
arqueas forman un grupo esencialmente
que son los organismos procariotas
mientras que tenemos otro grupo que son
los educación test así que espero que
este vídeo te haya dado un buen panorama
de cómo son las cosas